the top business stories live from the
Sky News City Studio
the competition of markets regulator
extends the deadline for Microsoft's
multi-billion dollar takeover of the
game's publisher Activision Blizzard
our multi-million pound takeover The
Firm behind Franco Manker and the real
Greek full effect UK restaurant chains
also ahead a new two billion dollar
agreement encouraging investors to
reduce carbon emissions following Joe
Biden's visit to see the king
and the rally ready electric car I'll be
speaking with Ford As It prepares to
launch his newest EV at the Goodwood
Festival of speed
[Music]
good morning this is business live with
Ian King we start with some breaking
news and during the last 90 minutes the
UK's competition and markets Authority
has extended the deadline for its review
of Microsoft's takeover of the video
game publisher Activision Blizzard by
six weeks moving it from next Tuesday to
the 29th of August the extension will
give the Watchdog more time to review
proposals by the pair to resolve its
concerns the CMA said in April that it
was blocking the 69 billion dollar deal
which has since been waved through by
the European commission but which still
faces objections from U.S regulators
now last month saw the 93.4 million
pound takeover of Fulham Shore the owner
of Franco manca and the real Greek
casual dining chains approved by
shareholders the buyer is the Japanese
food service group Toledo torador
Holdings in partnership with the private
Equity Firm capezia so what does the
future hold for these two well-known
Brands who are with me now is Niels
Lauren he's co-founder and managing
director of capdisia good to see you
this morning there are currently some 27
real Greek restaurants and 70 Franco
manca pizzerias how many more can the
market sustain
good morning Ian and thank you for
having me well I think we we are very
optimistic about
um uh the growth potential for for both
Brands uh we've been following Fulham
Shore for a while now we're big big fans
of of uh both the Franco bank and the
real Greek Brands uh and we believe that
the the public markets were not valuing
the business properly uh Franco mancas
you know is an award-winning neopolitan
sourdough pizza concept founded in in
2008. the real Greek is an Eastern
Mediterranean family style concept
um both concepts are offered superb
authentic healthy food fast service and
a great dining experience at very
affordable prices which we think what is
what the UK needs
and in terms of the expansion plans
so we are looking uh we we started to
work with uh with the team uh in in
recent days already
um management and the entire team at
Franco manka and and the real Greek have
done a superb job over the last few
years uh we're now looking to improve
the business training ESG property
marketing it's a whole long list uh to
invest in the team to invest in in
current storage State and obviously to
to accelerate the new store rollout not
only in the UK but also uh abroad
International into Europe and
potentially other markets how how much
oh how many stores per year that's
that's remains to be seen but but we
we're we're definitely looking at Double
Digit uh store openings on an annual
basis obviously uh the the casual dining
market right now is facing a number of
headwinds Labor shortages higher food
and drink inflation do you see those
abating in the near future
we are we're very we're big Believers in
in UK Hospitality uh the industry as you
as you say is has gone through a lot
since 2020 covert hyperinflation
closures supply chain disruptions
interest rates going out for reduce
consumer spending
um like in any crisis this is forcing us
to adapt to become leaner better at what
we do to embrace technology which is a
big part of what's driving this industry
and to make changes in a way that in the
way we do things without ever
compromising on the quality of the food
um and the experience that we bring to
uh to to to customers
um I mean looking forward we are
optimistic about the future
um the the the UK and European
um uh industry uh restaurant industry
remains vastly under penetrating and on
the penetrated in terms of branded
technology enabled Concepts that offer
premium food and great customer
experience at affordable prices
um and and to put things in in
perspective perhaps the U.S restaurant
sector which we we know very well has
doubled in size over the past 15 years
and it has now surpassed groceries in
terms of per capita spent uh we are only
at the very beginning of that journey in
the UK and Europe and this obviously
provides for a very attractive business
and investment opportunities going
forward
and for those who aren't familiar with
your partner in this acquisition toridor
tell me a little about their business in
Japan
uh Toradol is is
um one of the largest and and most
successful publicly listed uh groups in
Japan uh they were founded in babai
Visionary entrepreneur and CEO currently
uh Takaya Wata in in 1990
uh today toridol is um
um is publicly listed has over 1700
restaurants in 36 countries across 15
different different brands
um and we decided to to team up with
them on this particular transaction
um particularly because we
we share the same values in terms of
Integrity authenticity of the the
products and services we provide quality
in provenance of product customer
service
um how we treat employees sustainability
um so together Toradol and cabezia bring
over 50 years of combined experience in
in operating and investing in
restaurants which we believe will will
benefit Fulham Shore and just to go back
to something that you said earlier you
you mentioned there you were looking at
property as a key part of it are you
seeing a lot of opportunities now are
you seeing sites becoming vacant that
you might be interested in
yes the the the counter to
um the the cost of living crisis that
we're seeing is obviously that the the
property Market in the UK is becoming
much more attractive than it was and
we're seeing a great deals across the UK
uh and and we think that that will
continue for the next uh at least for
the next couple of years so we are very
much focused on on that and and we will
take advantage of that that property
Market uh this location
very good news very good to see you this
morning we do appreciate you joining us
thank you thank you very much
now earlier this week on route to the
NATO Summit President Biden met the king
at Windsor Castle along with the
president's climate Envoy John Kerry and
the UK Energy Secretary Grant chaps the
pair also staged a climate Finance
mobilization Forum during which they met
leading philanthropists and investors
focused on mobilizing finance to address
the climate crisis among those at the
meeting was Dr Andy Cooper chief
executive and founder of the
sustainability focused asset manager
LeapFrog Investments uh very good to see
this morning
um you announced a big initiative
yourself on the day you're committing
something like half a billion dollars
great to be here and yes we are going to
invest over 500 million dollars into
companies serving people who really need
green tools and Technologies products
and services to transition from very
carbon intensive Footprints to
carbon-like Footprints unless the people
in Emerging Markets get these kinds of
products and services we are all rarely
finished we have very little chance of
hitting that 1.5 degree warming Target
let alone something like two degrees I
mean this is a big commitment on on the
part of your firm how many investments
will that cover individual Investments
so we typically will invest roughly a
dozen in a dozen companies with that
kind of capital LeapFrog was started in
2007 uh today we have several billion
dollars under management and our
companies in these markets in the
Emerging Markets reach 450 million
people so that's about six percent of
the world's population what we think is
needed in climate and we've reached
those people with things like health
care or financial tools like insurance
or savings what we think is needed in
climate is something of a similar scale
we need Investments that really scale to
reach very large numbers of people
because there are four billion people
rising so if the West decarbonizers in
the rich countries decarbonize but these
countries see this immense growth
we will not reach those targets that the
world has set and we will really have a
climate catastrophe on all of our hands
today is the hottest day in the history
of Europe and that will be just the
beginning if we don't also address the
climate crisis in Emerging Markets so
the commitment that you've announced
this week will that be are you looking
for brand new investment opportunities
or might some of this go to some of your
existing portfolio companies this will
go into new investment opportunities in
these markets countries like India
Indonesia Vietnam Nigeria Kenya we have
seen very successful investments in the
space so for example we invested in Sun
King alongside General Atlantic and Sun
King is now the largest pay-as-you-go
solar distributor in the world it's
reached over a hundred million people a
company started in Kenya with
distributed solar where people can light
up their homes where historically
they've had to use kerosene or candles
which are incredibly inefficient
mechanisms and can be very destructive
ultimately for the environment so we see
a large number of opportunities in this
space coming through as all these
billions of emerging consumers look to
transition to two-wheeler scooters
through cars and buses as well as home
systems in solar and other similar
Technologies and at what stage are the
businesses you invest in at in their
their lives are you are you a VCU style
investor looking at early stage stuff or
do they have to be existing and is this
more sort of akin to private Equity
we're a private Equity growth investor
so it can be early stage or later stage
growth but these are companies that do
not have technology risk or deep
business model risk built into them and
what we're doing is we're taking them
from serving a few hundred thousand or a
few million people to serving tens of
millions of people and what is most
exciting about this moment in history is
that with the Advent of the mobile phone
and billions of smartphones joining the
economy you suddenly have have billions
and billions of people who are
immediately accessible to to new
companies and to companies that are
growing rapidly and you really see the
intensity of demand of these people for
things like Health Care climate
Solutions and financial services we are
at a moment in history that is much like
the internet was in the early 2000s
where there will be a very rapid
transition not only online but where
people will be adopting all these new
tools Technologies products and services
that help their families that help their
communities and help their companies to
thrive and the companies that really
serve that are scaling at a tremendous
rate just to give you a small stat
across the life of our companies uh of
and of our firm leapfro companies have
grown on average revenue at 24 a year
and that is in economies that are
growing it on average six percent a year
versus the current one percent oecd
average so you're getting 24 times times
the average growth within an oecd
country in these markets and risk has
gone down very very substantially so it
is a moment in history where I think
investors can have a very different
perspective
and I think the likes of John Kerry
Grant shapes and even meeting with the
king and the president deeply appreciate
that the whole financial and economic
environment has changed and the equation
for investors has changed fundamentally
good there's so much more I wanted to
ask you Andy we're out of time I'm
afraid you'll just have to come again no
problem good to see you thank you
some other business news stories for you
now and Burberry has credited a
continued recovery in China which is its
biggest single market after reporting
strong sales growth in recent weeks the
luxury fashion group said that during
the 13 weeks to the first of July its
retail sales were up 18 on the same
period a year ago on a comparable basis
stripping out mainland China sells for
up 11 During the period Burberry which
recently reopened its flagship store on
London's newborn Street said sales of
outerwear in particular its Heritage
rainware lines had grown by 36 percent
while sales of leather goods had
increased by 13 percent
ITV said this morning it was no longer
actively exploring the possible
acquisition of all three media the
production company behind such TV hits
as the BBC's called the Midwife Channel
4's gogglebox and itv's own Midsummer
murders well ITV said last month it was
actively exploring a deal to buy all
three media which is currently owned by
the U.S media Giants Warner Brothers
Discovery in Liberty Global with a price
tag of 1 billion pounds being widely
reported that the company said today
that was no longer the case it did say
however that it continued to monitor the
business
she has a McBride shot up by 19 this
morning after the cleaning products
maker said profits for the year would be
better than expected the company which
is Europe's biggest manufacturer of
white label cleaning products for the
domestic household and professional
cleaning markets said sales for the year
to the end of June were up 28.4 percent
on the previous 12 months it said across
most of its markets it was clear there
was a shift to private label products as
consumers shifted to better value
products in a bid to mitigate the
effects of inflation on their household
budgets
thank you
onto the markets now you've got a
glimpse of them a moment ago stocks in
the Asia Pacific region enjoyed a
largely positive session overnight
following more gains last night on more
streets uh than only the Nikkei in Tokyo
is slightly lower there the leading
performer in the region overnight was a
Cosby in South Korea that was up more
than one percent but in Europe stocks
are largely going into the weekend on a
negative note right now only the uh cat
carrant in France is in positive
territory very appropriate that for
Bastille Day you might say the main
talking point in Europe this morning is
Nokia the Finnish telecoms equipment
maker is down nearly 10 percent in
Helsinki following a profits warning
well here in London uh the ftse 100 is
uh just about in positive territory up
nearly a fifth of one percent right now
Falls in some of the mining and energy
stocks are balancing gains for
healthcare and consumer stocks the index
is I should say on course currently for
its best week since March the leading
Blue Chip gainer in percentage terms is
the engineer spirax based in
gloucestershire shares up three percent
right now after receiving a push from
one of the Brokers outside the ftse 100
the asset manager Ashmore it shares down
six and three quarter percent right now
following a trading update meanwhile Dr
Martens is ahead another six percent
following yesterday's trading update on
the foreign exchange markets really has
been very interesting this week the US
dollar currently heading for its worst
week since November following the benign
U.S inflation data on Wednesday as you
can see uh Sterling uh is off right now
a fifth of one percent against the
Greenback uh but that's close to a
15-month high against the U.S dollar
Sterling also off slightly against the
Euro single currency meanwhile Morrison
changed against the dollar the oil price
again it's been really interesting this
week uh the oil price tends to move in
inverse proportion to the door and it's
done that again today it hits its uh
highest level overnight the the oil
price since the 25th of April right now
barrel of Brent crew changing hands at
81.22 a barrel that's off a six of one
percent who are joining me now is Sophie
Lund Yates she of course is the lead
Equity Analyst at Hargreaves Lansdowne
Sophie good to see you this morning
um let's start with Burberry because uh
I thought quite an upbeat trading
statement from them this morning
hi good morning great to be back you are
right I mean you know this they've seen
a 19 uplift in retail Revenue that's
certainly not something I'm going to
knock
um but one thing that that does need a
close eye on it is the fact that this
this great rebound that we've seen
particularly from mainland China you
know that's a 46 uplift it's actually
masking an eight percent dip in the
Americas
um so that really does suggest that
under the hood potentially there's some
some underlying demand concerns in that
in that region
um but obviously overall the picture is
certainly a positive one
um but there is going to need to be a
close eye on what's going on there in
the in the Americas
now what about this ITV acquisition from
all three media people got very excited
about this only a few weeks ago it's
obviously not gone off the ground I mean
these things normally fall apart on uh
on price do we have any inkling as to
what's happened
there's not a huge amount of
transparency going on here you know
there was only kind of some initial
interest that was being floated it
wasn't really and particularly far down
the line and in terms of the market
reaction that we're seeing from ITV
today you know last time I looked they
were down about
um one on a bit percent
um is the fact that ITV is going to have
to find some way to Pedal more revenue
from its Studio business you know it's
got this really successful production
business itself so this was potentially
going to be an acquisition that was
going to help it to offset
um that kind of structural decline that
that was going on in its in its
advertising business
um so that's where the market reaction
where ITV is concerned is is stemming
from and certainly I think potentially
the loss of a potentially good
opportunity but we have to trust that
there was good good reason behind um
shutting the door on this potential deal
and yesterday obviously we had uh quite
a downbeat trading update from Barrett
the shares again under a bit of a cloud
this morning
yes absolutely I mean they shed about
two three percent yesterday and there's
not really any respite
um today and the reason I think this is
an important one to talk about is simply
the the level the the scope of the
numbers that Barrett was talking about
obviously a very important and big house
Builder here in the UK they are
expecting a 20 drop
um in build completion than the coming
Financial Year and that comes as demand
uh the demand environment is apparently
incredibly challenging and this is
perhaps not surprising given that you
know the huge Shake uh or the huge
shakes going through the mortgage Market
um but really this is something that is
likely going to have a significant read
across for the other house builders you
know who we'll be hearing from in the
coming
um in the coming weeks as well as
earnings season kicks off um so really
just huge numbers you know that 20 drops
don't want to hop on about it too much
but that is really really very
significant and that's why the shares
are still struggling in The Wider sector
today absolutely Sophie got to leave it
there I'm afraid lovely to see you again
have a great weekend thank you
thanks
still to come here on business live
electric rallying I'll be speaking with
Ford As It prepares to launch its newest
electric vehicle at the Goodwood
Festival of speed stay with us
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
independent United Kingdom
these last few years have seen some huge
stories
[Music]
and these stories have been driven by
politics by politicians the people in
power you must stay at home and it's my
job to figure out how these decisions
made by politicians impact all of us in
our everyday lives this is the worst
thing I've ever been through in my life
people turn up here with their child's
stuff in a black sack and just say I
don't want to and that is what it is
it's first class poverty is this an
example of the welfare state failing
take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world these are stories
that affect us all
billions of children are now having to
catch up some stories have changed all
of our Lives because like the residents
the staff are being infected politicians
they make decisions all of the time and
it's our job to hold them to account I
wonder if you will take this opportunity
to apologize to those families but in
the end the real power doesn't actually
lie with the politicians the real power
lies with the people
I'm Nick Martin I'm the people and
politics correspondent at Sky News
[Music]
foreign
above the clouds you know why
because this is the Emirates a 380.
[Music]
yeah
Emirates slide better
welcome back now Ford well today unveil
a new variant of its electric vehicle
the Mustang Mach e at the 2023 Goodwood
Festival of speed little is known about
the new vehicle although there is
speculation it will be equipped with
wheels for off-road driving while the
launch comes amid a 50 billion dollar
investment in electrical Vehicles by
Ford worldwide it's aiming to build some
600 000 EVS this year alone well joining
me now from the Goodwood Festival of
speed is the vice president of electric
vehicles at Ford Darren Palmer Darren
good to see you this morning I know you
haven't unveiled this car yet but give
us a clue is it is this a rally car or
an off-roader
yes so we're about to unveil the Mustang
Mac e rally which is a rally version of
the Mustang Machi with high performance
but it can also take that off-road and
how much is this going to cost
well we're not revealing new prices just
yet we're just giving a teaser today
showing what the vehicle's about and
we're going to also run it up the hill
but you can see what it can do I mean
obviously electric vehicles contain
quite heavy batteries will that this
have the identical performance of a sort
of petrol equivalence
so this is going to show what an
electric vehicle can really do off-road
because of the immense power and torque
that these electric vehicles have and
how quickly you can control those the
off-road performance is absolutely
amazing and so we're going to use this
as a test pens to show people what it
can really do
and is this going to be available all
around the world at the same time
yes it is it should be available in
Europe and UK and America coming soon uh
for next year and it'll be available all
around the world
now you're investing as I said 50
billion dollars in in EVS how long do
you anticipate that investment taking to
pay for itself
well one of the important things is that
it's an inflection point right now for
electric vehicles and we believe you
need to make them extremely exciting so
that people have the desire to want them
and that is this performance and these
are cars like the one we're showing
today just the software and it's
important for the investment in now
because we expect a huge uptick in
volume in the coming years so we're
already coming to the point now as that
scale Rises we'll see the cars coming
into profitability and that's important
for the companies as well because we're
here also to drive a profitable company
there's been a lot of talk recently that
your production in the US is
outstripping demand and that dealers
answer turning over Macy's as rapidly as
they once were what's the situation
so we've been constrained on Productions
since the day we launched the Mustang
machiave and the F-150 Lightning and the
e-transit so we could not meet customer
demand and we are just now bringing
online more volume some three times as
much volume for the Mustang might be
clearly quadruple the volume for the
F-150 lighting and similar for the
project so we're just about bringing
that volume in now and we're also
bringing new derivatives like the LSD
battery that will allow us to offer a
more attainable price for customers and
it's literally just coming in this month
so we'll see what that does for demand
for the second half of the year but you
should see some more attractive prices
in these vehicles and entering in
slightly different segments and how has
the Mackie been selling elsewhere around
the world I mean I gather in China it
struggled to make Headway against some
of the local Brands out there
so nothing Mickey has been sold out in
the US and in Europe since the day
launched and we're still continues
continuing to see very high demand
before we add these extra derivatives we
haven't quite seen that demand in China
for the vehicle there is huge huge
competition now in China so we're making
modifications to the vehicles to deal
with that but in the US and Europe he's
done extremely well
now closer to home of course Ford
stopped making the Ford Fiesta last week
uh Britain's best-selling car for many
many years now I've seen suggestions
that that may resurface as an electric
vehicle anything you can tell us on that
well that's the vehicle very close to my
heart as I worked on that vehicle and
launched it so as we now move into the
electric domain you'll see the vehicle
behind me here is the um Ford Explorer
which is launching next year and that's
a more affordable SUV style small
vehicle to to bring to a larger part of
the market we're also working on many
others and you know that we've got the
purine Market which is extremely
successful people are really liking that
slightly more SUV crossover style and
that's becoming very popular so we're
going to move some of those into the
electric domain first I'd say and uh
briefly if you would brief down
obviously the EU has watered down its
rules on when it's going to be phasing
out petrol and Diesel is the UK moving
too rapidly by seeking to ban petrol and
Diesel by 2013 new vehicles
well we believe we're all in in board
and we believe that customers are going
to desire and they're going to want
these products it just takes some time
for education and to have them available
across different types of vehicle and
the prices that people want so we
believe people the customers are going
to want these so we're all in on that we
are want to be cautious with some of the
tariffs because we don't want the
tourists to get ahead of where we can
put the supply chain in place because we
want the best pricing for customers to
help Drive demand for TV
all right um we have to leave it there
it's good luck with the launch good to
talk to you again thank you thank you
very much for your time
that's it from me I'm back at half past
four this afternoon with our afternoon
edition of business rival at Fortis
seeing you then thanks for joining me
[Music]